aquí tenemos un espectro de rm de protón
para la molécula que tiene una fórmula
molecular de 65 h 10 o 2 y empecemos
calculando el índice de deficiencia de
hidrógeno
si tenemos 5 carbonos podemos tener un
máximo de 2 x 5 más dos hidrógenos y eso
es igual a 12 12 hidrógenos es el número
máximo para 5 carbonos aquí solo tenemos
10 hidrógenos y entonces nos hacen falta
dos hidrógenos nos hace falta un par de
hidrógenos por eso podemos decir que él
h es igual a 1 y cuando el líder es
igual a 1 inmediatamente pienso que un
doble enlace está presente en esta
molécula o un anillo está presente en
esta molécula y luego seguimos con los
valores de integración para esta señal
tenemos un valor de integración de 33.2
para esta 48.4 para esta 33.3 y luego
48.7 y dividimos todos los valores de
integración entre el más bajo el más
bajo
sería 33.2
33.2 dividido entre 30 y 3.2
obviamente es igual a 1
48.4 dividido entre 30 y 3.2 es
aproximadamente 1.5 33.3 dividido entre
30 y 3.2 obviamente es muy cercano a 1 y
finalmente 48.7 dividido entre 30 y 3.2
nos da aproximadamente 1.5 y estos
números dicen la proporción relativa de
protones que nos están dando estas
cuatro señales tenemos que pensar en 10
protones cierto tenemos a 10 hidrógenos
aquí y entonces esto solo es relativo
para obtener el número absoluto de
hidrógenos necesitamos multiplicar a
estos números y esta proporción por 2 si
multiplicamos 1 por 2
obviamente obtenemos 2 así que esta
señal representa 2 protones
multiplica 1.5 por 2 y obtendríamos 3
así que esta señal representa 3 protones
multiplica 1 por 2 esta señal es de 2
protones 1.5 por 2 esta señal es de 3
protones
ahora veamos a cada señal una por una
empezamos con la señal que tiene dos
protones aquí en la izquierda dos
protones estamos hablando del grupo ch2
déjame continuar dibujando un grupo ch2
aquí cuantos protones vecinos para este
grupo ch2 podemos saber eso pensando en
la regla de n 1
si tenemos n protones vecinos
esperaríamos ver n mazón picos así que
cuantos picos tenemos 1 2 3 tres picos
al número de vecinos solo le restas 13
menos uno es 2
estos dos protones en el ch 2 tienen dos
protones vecinos ahora pensemos en el
desplazamiento químico esta señal tiene
un desplazamiento químico
aproximadamente de 4 partes por millón y
ese es el máximo valor para el
desplazamiento químico de todas estas
cuatro señales y esa en la región para
un protón que está conectado a un
carbono que está unido a un átomo
electro negativo y si vemos nuestra
fórmula molecular tenemos 2
oxígenos aquí así que tomaré uno de esos
oxígenos y pondré ese oxígeno en ese
carbono porque nuevamente cuando estás
pensando en la señal para un protón en
un carbono que está unido a un átomo
electro negativo obtienes un
desplazamiento químico en este caso de
un valor aproximado a cuatro partes por
millón porque el oxígeno está
deslindando a esos protones el oxígeno
está quitando densidad electrónica
esa es una pieza del rompecabezas ahora
continuamos con las siguientes piezas
del rompecabezas esta será la siguiente
pieza de nuestro rompecabezas tengo 3
protones por lo que eso es un grupo
metilo déjame continuar dibujando un
grupo metilo aquí tenemos ch 3 cuantos
protones vecinos hay para esos protones
del metilo bueno veremos un pico aquí 1
tenemos cero protones vecinos pensamos
ahora en el desplazamiento químico el
desplazamiento químico está apenas
pasando dos partes por millón y eso está
en la región donde los protones están
justo al lado de un carbón y lo
continuamos dibujando un carbón y lo
aquí y suponemos que el carbono
carbónico está unido a otro carbón y lo
aquí eso tiene sentido en términos de
números de vecinos observa que el
agregar el carbón y lo satisface el vih
y se encarga del segundo oxígeno en la
fórmula molecular ahora déjame utilizar
azul para esto la señal para estos tres
protones hay cero vecinos y si vamos a
este carbono
si hay un carbono por aquí no hay
protones en este carbono carbón el ico y
entonces eso explica esta pieza del
rompecabezas siguiente señal ch2
dibujaré una c h 2
aquí cuántos vecinos es un poco difícil
verlo 1 2
456 picos 6 15 esperaríamos cinco
vecinos usando la fórmula sobre
simplificada de n 1 y volveremos a s ch
2 ahora finalmente tenemos una señal con
3 protones
h 3
cuántos vecinos para estos protones del
metilo tenemos 123 picos
3 - 1 es 22 vecinos bien pongamos todas
estas tres piezas del rompecabezas
juntas y dibujemos la estructura final
de puntos empecemos con este pedazo del
rompecabezas justo aquí tenemos un
carbón y lo dibujaré mi carbón y lo aquí
y luego tenemos nuestro grupo metilo
unido a ese carbón y lo dibujamos
nuestro grupo metilo de esta manera y
usamos azul para estos protones del
metilo la señal para estos protones del
metilo está aquí ahora pensemos en el
posible grupo funcional tenemos un
carbón hilo y luego por aquí tenemos a
un oxígeno si ponemos al oxígeno al lado
del carbón y lo eso nos da un este
continuamos haciendo eso pongamos al
oxígeno justo al lado
junto al carbón ido y luego unido a ese
oxígeno tenemos un ch2 dibujo mi ch2 ahí
e identifiquemos a esos protones los
protones en magenta nos están dando esta
señal de aquí luego pensemos en usemos
rojo
pensemos en estos protones estos
protones del metilo esos protones del
metilo tienen dos vecinos y para que
tenga sentido serían estos dos vecinos
de aquí
estos desplazamientos químicos están por
debajo de dos esos están relativamente
alejados del oxígeno dibujemos los
protones del metilo tenemos nuestros
protones del metilo justo aquí y hagamos
los rojos
resaltemos esos estos protones del
metilo aquí nos están dando esta señal y
luego finalmente tenemos un ch 2
restante justo aquí dibujamos nuestro
ch2 y hagámoslo verde
estos dos protones aquí en verde nos
están dando esta señal ahora veamos si
todo tiene sentido empecemos con el
protón verde predijimos cinco vecinos
cierto así que vemos al carbono y los
protones verdes están ahí vamos al
carbono vecino 123 protones vecinos
vamos al otro protón vecino 12 es un
total de 5 vecinos eso es lo que
predijimos con la regla de n 1 en la
realidad los protones rojos y magenta
están en diferentes ambientes y entonces
esta regla sobre simplificada de n 1 no
está exactamente correcta pero
corresponde a lo que vemos en el
espectro de rm n podemos continuar con
esto que tenemos nos ayuda a imaginarnos
la estructura de la molécula
esto tiene sentido cinco vecinos aquí
continuamos con los protones en rojo
predijimos dos vecinos para el protón en
rojo así que vamos con el carbono vecino
este carbono tiene al protón rojo si
vamos al carbono vecino vemos dos
vecinos por lo que esto tiene sentido
muy bien veamos los protones magenta
para estos pre dijimos dos vecinos los
protones magenta están en este carbono
vamos al carbono vecino y veo 12 vecinos
por lo que esto tiene sentido y luego
finalmente los protones en azul por aquí
predijimos 0 vecinos y vamos al protón
vecino y vemos que no hay protones en
este carbono no tiene vecinos y por eso
tenemos a nuestro singlete por aquí
esto tiene sentido el desplazamiento
químico tiene sentido el desdoblamiento
tiene sentido todo parece tener sentido
para este este una cosa que he notado
cuando los estudiantes tienen un
problema con un esther es porque algunas
veces hacen al revés el esther déjame
mostrarte lo que quiero decir he visto a
muchos estudiantes hacer esto en
exámenes lo que hacen es que identifican
el hecho de que tienen un esther pero en
este caso pone en el grupo metilo en el
oxígeno y luego dibuja en el resto de la
molécula por aquí 3 carbonos 1 2 3
y escribirán esto como su respuesta en
el examen y por qué está esto mal esto
está mal porque la señal para estos
protones de metilo está justo al lado de
este oxígeno este oxígeno está
deslindando obtendremos un singlete para
estos protones del metilo pero la señal
estaría más cerca a cuatro partes por
millón y no a dos partes por millón y
entonces esa es una señal de cómo
ensamblar las piezas para un este piensa
en lo que está junto a este oxígeno de
aquí y piensa en los desplazamientos
químicos y no cometerás ese error
para este espectro de rm en la molécula
tiene una fórmula molecular de c4 h 10
y calculemos el índice de deficiencia de
hidrógeno así que si tenemos 4 carbonos
el número máximo de hidrógenos que
podemos tener es 2 x 4 + 2 que es igual
a 10 y esa es la cantidad de hidrógenos
que tenemos en nuestra fórmula molecular
esta vez no nos hace falta ningún
hidrógeno y entonces el vih es igual a 0
y no esperaríamos un enlace doble o un
anillo ningún enlace doble o anillo para
la estructura de puntos
para la integración esta señal es un
protón esta señal es de 3 protones y
esta señal de aquí es de 6 protones
enfoquémonos en estas señales tenemos de
un protón
continuaré dibujando a este protón en un
carbono de esta manera
pensemos en cuántos vecinos tiene ese
protón ver los picos
tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6
siete picos 716 ese protón tendrá seis
protones vecinos y déjame colorearlo
esta es la señal para este protón
magenta el desplazamiento químico está
alrededor de cuatro partes por millón y
ese es el desplazamiento químico que
esperaríamos si ese protón estuviera en
un carbono unido a un átomo electro
negativo y tenemos un oxígeno aquí
continuaré poniendo un oxígeno justo
aquí unido a ese carbono porque el
oxígeno está quitando densidad
electrónica lejos de ese protón está
deslindando a ese protón dándole un
desplazamiento químico más alto
movámonos a la siguiente señal tenemos 3
protones esto sería un grupo metilo
tenemos 3 protones del metilo cuántos
protones vecinos para esos protones del
metilo tenemos solo un pico aquí 1 menos
100 protones vecinos y el desplazamiento
químico está alrededor de 3.5 partes por
millón así que esos protones del metilo
deberán de estar muy cerca a ese oxígeno
entonces obtenemos un valor más grande
para ese desplazamiento químico y
entonces podemos poner los protones del
metilo por aquí en la parte izquierda
del oxígeno
eso tiene sentido en términos del
desplazamiento químico y también tiene
sentido en términos del número de
vecinos esos tres protones de aquí nos
dan esta señal y tenemos cero vecinos
cierto así que no hay vecinos para estos
tres protones continuamos con la última
señal tenemos seis protones esos son
como dos grupos de metido tenemos dos
grupos de metilo aquí y la señal está
desdoblada en un 'doblete' por lo que
vemos dos picos aquí 2 - 1 es 1
esperamos a un vecino para estos dos
grupos metilo y obviamente tendría que
ser este protón en magenta porque sólo
nos quedan estos dos lugares vacíos
cierto ponemos a estos grupos metilo
justo aquí
y podemos ver que obtenemos un vecino
esos dos grupos metilo están más lejos
del oxígeno relativamente debido a la
señal teniendo un valor menor para el
desplazamiento químico usemos rojo aquí
rojo para estos 6 protones
nos da esta señal y tenemos un protón
vecino es este protón en magenta por
aquí pensemos en el protón magenta
dijimos que el protón magenta tendría
seis vecinos y eso es lo que vemos tres
de este metilo y tres de éste metido
seis vecinos para el protón magenta y
luego finalmente vimos que habrían cero
vecinos para los protones en azul y eso
es lo que vemos para nuestra estructura
de puntos y entonces esta molécula es un
éter este espectro rm n representa a
éste